RACHEL DEMPSEY: Welcome to the
RStudio Enterprise community
meetup.
I'm Rachel Dempsey.
I'll be your host for today's
R in supply chain meetup.
I'm joined by my
colleague and co-host
for today Curtis Kephart if
you want to say hello, as well,
Curtis.
CURTIS KEPHART: Hi, everyone.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: And
we're also joined
by our two awesome speakers
for today, Laura Darby
Rose and Ralph Asher.
If you just joined now, feel
free to introduce yourselves
to the chat window, as
well, and say hello.
Maybe include where
you're calling in from.
But just to go
through a brief agenda
while we wait for a few
others from the waiting room,
we'll go through
some introductions
of the meet up, have two
awesome presentations,
intro to supply chain
design with Ralph
Asher and forecasting
demand with Laura Rhodes.
We'd like to also use today's
meet up to kick off a supply
chain working group, too.
And Curtis Kephart
from our team will
give us some more
information on that
and how to join if
this is something
that's interesting to you.
And then lastly, we'll open it
up for additional audience Q&amp;A
and just open discussion
among everyone.
I did mute everybody upon entry
right now, but towards the end,
we will unmute.
But if you do have
questions during any
of the presentations, we do have
a Slido link that you can use.
So you can ask anonymously
or include your name there,
as well.
And we'll share that in
the Zoom window right now.
That will really help us
to organize questions, too.
And you can upvote
people's questions.
And just a quick note
that the recording
will be shared up to the
RStudio YouTube, as well.
So if you want to
share it with anyone,
or go back and listen later,
that will be shared up there.
One other housekeeping
note, if you
want to turn on
live transcription
during the meeting,
you can do so, as well.
And that's offered in
the Zoom bar below.
And Curtis, if you could
go to the next slide.
Awesome.
For anyone who is joining
for the first time today,
I'd love to welcome you
to this meetup group.
This is a friendly and
open meetup environment
for teams to share
the work that they're
doing within their
organizations,
teach lessons learned,
network with others,
and really just allow us all
to learn from each other.
So thank you all for making
this a welcoming community.
I really want to create a space
where everybody can participate
and we can hear from everyone.
So I want to reiterate that.
We love to hear from
everyone, no matter
your level of experience
in the field, as well.
If you ever have suggestions,
or general feedback,
or want to speak
at a future meetup,
I'll share a few links
in the chat window right
after this, as well.
But with all of
that, I would love
to introduce our first
speaker today, Ralph Asher.
Ralph is the founder of
Data Driven Supply Chain,
and prior to founding
Ralph worked as an
operations research scientist
in corporate supply
chain functions
at Target and General Mills.
And so with that, I will
turn it over to you, Ralph.
RALPH ASHER: All right,
thank you, Rachel,
for the introduction.
Hello to everyone who's on this
webinar, wherever you may be.
Just reading through
the chat, sounds
like we have a global presence
already, and that's great.
I really appreciate
the opportunity
to speak with you today.
As mentioned, my
name is Ralph Asher,
and today, I'll be talking about
supply chain network design.
What is it, first off?
And how can we use open source
languages like R IN Python
to design supply chains?
So I'll share my screen,
and hopefully, this
will go off without a hitch.
All right, so a
little about myself.
Like many on this call, I have
a math and science background.
I have a bachelor's in
physics and a master's
in operations research.
I started my career after
college in the military.
I was on active duty in the
Marine Corps for several years,
and I've been serving as a
reserve marine in a part time
capacity for about
10 years since then.
After military, I worked
in supply chain design
and simulation for eight years
at General Mills and Target
here in beautiful, cold
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
I left the corporate
world last summer
to form my consulting firm.
If you're interested in
learning more about that, please
reach out.
In addition to
running my company
and serving in the
Marine reserve,
I'm also an adjunct at the
University of Minnesota
business school, where
I teach statistics.
I've been an R user for
10 years, since 2012,
and I've really
found the language
to be an ever increasingly
versatile tool for my work.
I've also loved maps,
and math, and programming
since I was a little kid so
I'm kind of fortunate that I've
found a career field that
lets me merge these interests.
So supply chains, from the
back office to the front page.
The COVID-19
pandemic, it's really
caused unprecedented disruption
to global supply chains.
Manufacturing
shutdowns, as well as
labor shortages and
a dramatic shift
in consumer spending
from services to goods,
have caused massive disruptions
to the previously invisible
flow of materials.
This disruption can be seen in
the container ships waiting off
the coast of
Southern California,
waiting to dock in Los
Angeles and Long Beach.
It can be seen in the
reconsideration of reshoring
American manufacturing capacity
or the delays in building
and repairing homes due
to supply shortages.
It can be seen in the inflation
that you see at the store
shelves and at the gas pump.
And even Santa Claus
can't fix these problems,
and he has the most
advanced logistics operation
known to mankind, or elfkind.
Instead, the task of
ensuring supply chains
continue to function
so we literally
have food on our plate
and fuel in our cars, that
falls to the legions of hard
working supply chain management
professionals.
And as a data
scientist, I'm really
quite proud to be able to use
my quantitative technical skills
to help these efforts.
So you may be
asking yourself, how
can analytics be used in the
management of supply chains.
Depending upon your
background, this slide
may be old news
to you, but I find
it's useful to
discuss supply chain
analytics in the framework
of descriptive, predictive,
and prescriptive analytics.
Now, descriptive analytics,
the biggest and most important
part of the pyramid, includes
business intelligence
and diagnostic analytics
of the supply chain.
How many of my trucks
arrived on time?
How productive were my
manufacturing plants
and my warehouses?
How are these metrics trending,
and are any of them worrisome?
Predictive analytics is next.
How do we predict
what's going to happen
next in our supply chain?
That includes things
like sales forecasting,
as that will be discussed
next, as well as forecasting
costs for your
supply chain inputs
and some types of
supply chain simulation.
Finally, the top of
the pyramid, which,
by volume, should occupy
the least amount of time
is prescriptive analytics.
What should I do
with my supply chain?
This is my wheelhouse
and includes
things like supply chain
network design, discussed today,
as well as inventory
optimization and other types
of supply chain simulation.
Now, a key point
for this audience,
especially, is that open
source technologies are really
changing the landscape in supply
chain management and supply
chain analytics.
When you look at each
of these capabilities,
you can mentally pick out
which R or Python packages
you could use for them.
This really is a sea change from
when I started in the supply
chain analytics field
about a decade ago,
when the toolkit consisted
of Excel for data analysis,
SPSS for statistics, and
commercial visualization
software like Tableau.
So what is supply
chain network design?
Put plainly, it's the
strategic analysis
of the locations and activities
of the various elements
of the firm's supply chain.
For example, if
I'm a manufacturer,
where should I locate
warehouses for my raw materials,
the stuff I use to
make other stuff,
or my semi-finished
goods, which are
items that are only partway
through the manufacturing
process?
Where should I put my
manufacturing facilities,
my plants?
Where should they go?
Where should I put my
distribution centers,
my warehouses for
finished goods?
Where should they be located?
And if I'm a
retailer, how should
I use my stores as a
link in my supply chain?
For example, many
leading retailers,
including my former
employer Target,
use their stores
as strategic assets
for shipping e-commerce orders.
Well, from where
should we do that?
That's a big question.
That's a supply chain
network design question.
Supply chain
network design seeks
to answer these big
questions, all with the intent
to understand the impacts on
profitability, cost, service,
and other key metrics and with
a goal to minimize or maximize
one or two key metrics,
usually cost or profitability.
Today, I'll be focusing on
a relatively simple example
of supply chain network design,
a distribution network with two
echelons, the distribution
centers, or warehouses,
and customers that are
serviced by those warehouses.
In designing the
supply chain, we
ask ourselves, given a customer
base of demand aggregated
to a city level,
one, where should we
open distribution centers
to satisfy that demand,
and two, what customers should
be serviced by, or aligned to,
each distribution center?
While most real life supply
chain design problems are much,
much more complex
than this example,
I hope it will be informative
on how practitioners approach
these kinds of problems and
how we can use open source
technology for them.
So how do we do this?
How can we answer
these questions?
We can answer them with
optimization modeling.
Optimization modeling is
a mathematical technique
that allows a
practitioner to optimize
a set of interconnected
decisions, where
the decisions are constrained
by real world limitations.
Optimization solvers take
the decision options,
formulate it as a
mathematical model,
and return the set of decisions
that optimizes, minimizes
or maximizes, an equation
that includes the decisions
as inputs.
This equation is formally
known as an objective function.
If anyone on here has an
operations research background,
I realize it's not the precise
mathematical definition,
but I find it to be useful
in explaining the field.
So in our case, the decisions
we need to make are one,
how many distribution
centers to open
and where should we locate them
and two, what customers rely
on each distribution center?
You can see that
these decisions,
they're interconnected because
I can't align a customer
to a distribution
center in a certain city
unless I also open
a distribution
center in that city.
And the limitations on our
decisions, or our constraints,
they're, one, that all
customer demand must be met.
We may have a minimum or maximum
number of distribution centers.
We may really only realistically
open distribution centers
in certain locations.
So we have to start with
a candidate set of cities.
We may have a maximum volume
per distribution center.
It's also called the capacity.
And for certain reasons, we
may put a maximum distance
between a customer and its
servicing distribution center,
and we'll see that
later in an example.
So we'll shortly
transition to the shiny app
I built for the
webinar, but first, I'll
introduce the scenario.
Now, because this is
a simplified scenario,
this is a simplified
version of an app I would
use for a regular project.
You are supply chain data
scientist at Heartland Widgets,
Incorporated.
Your company is
the market leader
in widget sales across
an eight-state area
of the American Midwest.
The pandemic-induced
shift in consumer demand
from services to goods, as
well as stay at home orders,
has led to a boom in demand
for your company's flagship
product, the at-home widget.
Faced with record
demand, the director
of supply chain network planning
has asked you to, quote,
reimagine the company's
distribution network.
You are to recommend where to
open Heartland's Distribution
Centers, as well as the
customer-to-distribution-center
alignment to achieve
a minimal cost.
Heartland Widgets has customers
in 117 Midwestern cities,
spread from the Dakotas
in the West, all the way
to my home state of
Indiana and East.
Each city's demand is
proportional to its population.
So for example, Chicago,
Illinois, which is a big city,
may have heard of
it, has more demand
than Fargo, North Dakota.
Heartland is
considering 20 cities
for potential
distribution center sites.
Because each distribution center
will cost $1 million to open,
it may not be cost effective
to open distribution centers
in all 20 cities.
But we're keeping
our options open.
So let's get a little
bit more technical here.
The decisions we need to
make for Heartland Widgets
can be represented by variables.
When we ask what
customer should we
align to which
distribution center,
this is equivalent to asking a
set of yes, no decisions that
must be made in concert.
For each customer
city I, should I
service it by a distribution
center in city J, yes or no?
In making our
decisions, we're limited
to having exactly one
yes per customer city.
It has to be serviced by
exactly one distribution center.
Relatedly, we need
to make decisions
about how many distribution
centers to open
and where to locate them.
This is a series of
if, then decisions
related to alignment decisions.
If at least one customer is
aligned to a distribution
center in, for example,
Omaha, Nebraska,
then we must open a
distribution center in Omaha.
The decision sets
are interconnected.
We cannot separate our
decisions on where to locate
our distribution centers from
our decisions on how to align
customers to
distribution centers.
Mathematical optimization
and, more specifically,
the techniques of linear
and integer programming
are ideal for making these
kinds of interrelated decisions.
When we use mathematical
optimization,
including for
supply chain design,
we're trying to
minimize or maximize
some equation that is the
function of our decisions.
In this example,
Heartland Widgets
wants to design the supply chain
with the lowest total cost.
The supply chain
costs in this example
are, one, the opening cost for
distribution centers, which
are priced at $1 million
each, two, the handling
costs with the
distribution centers, which
is one cent per
unit, per widget,
and three, the transportation
costs from distribution
centers to customers, which
are five cents per unit mile.
Now, a unit mile is
moving one unit one mile.
So for example, if you have
two widgets, two units,
and you move them
100 miles, that's
2 times 100, 200 unit miles.
At $0.05 each, that's $10 to
move to two units 100 miles.
You add up these
three cost components,
and it leads to the
total supply chain cost
that we're trying to minimize.
Now, one of the tenets
of supply chain design
is that these cost components
can be inversely related
to each other.
For example, the more
distribution centers you have,
the closer you are on
average to your customers.
And if you're closer to
your customers, on average,
you're going to spend less on
getting the product to them,
on that transportation cost,
because it's just closer.
However, the more
distribution centers you have,
the more you spend to open
them in the first place.
So there's an
inverse relationship
between the distribution
center opening
cost and the transportation
cost to get the product
to your customer.
The more distribution centers
you have, the more cost
to open them, and the less you
spend on the transportation,
inverse relationship.
Optimization modeling helps us
figure out these relationships
and find the optimal solution
that takes into account
the relationships
between the costs.
All right, so because
this is R meetup
and I'm going to
demo a Shiny app,
I want to go over
the packages I used.
This is a tidyverse-centric
solution for data prep,
but I also use DT,
data table, and vroom.
Shinydashboard is used
for visualization,
and I use rhandsontable to
allow for interactive adjustment
to input tables.
Leaflet is used as
a mapping solution.
And the core of the
optimization modeling
rests with the ompr package
and the open source symphony
optimization solver.
As an aside, the COIN-OR
Foundation, the organization
that maintains symphony and
other open source optimization
tools like pulp and
piano for Python users,
they need financial help.
Please consider donating
via that GitHub link.
All right.
From here I'm going
to work from the app,
but I have slides for backup in
case of technical difficulties.
I host my app on Shinyapps.io.
You'll see the address, but to
avoid having technical issues,
I'd ask that nobody try to load
it while I'm giving the demo.
All right.
So this is a pretty
sparse app because it's
a fairly simple example.
And first step is
uploading our data.
So we really only have two sets
of input data, our customer
information and our
distribution center information.
I've prepped the data.
So we can you use room here.
And these are small files,
but even if they were large,
it'd still upload pretty quickly
because we're using room.
And saying yes, it's
going to be used.
All right.
So now I'm going to
inspect this upload data
and talk a little
bit through it.
First our customer data.
So our customers
are as mentioned
117 Midwestern cities.
And for each of these, we have
city names, state, latitude
and longitude,
their demand, which
is proportional to
their population.
And then we have this
column called maximum miles
to distribution center.
You'll see later on in an
example how we would use this.
Essentially if you want to
enforce a maximum distance
from a customer to the
distribution center that
services it, you would set this
column to that distance limit.
Right now I don't
care about that,
so I set this number so insanely
high that it doesn't really
matter.
Finally, we have this
column called Include,
and this is a nice thing
about using our hands on table
because you can actually
dynamically update
the table that you use
later on in your app.
So everything has
a checkmark here.
If I uncheck any of
these, they would not
be used in the
optimization model.
So we're going to
display the customer map.
You see these 117 cities
across the Midwest.
And just as an example of
how R Hands on Table works,
I wanted to get rid of
Rapid City, South Dakota.
You see it's down here.
Now it's gone.
But I do care about
our Rapid City,
so I'm going to keep it back.
All right.
So that's how we're using our
hands on table for the customer
inputs.
Distribution center similarly.
We have 20 candidate cities
across the Midwest for--
to put our distribution
centers in.
We have a latitude
our longitude,
our capacity, which
is the maximum volume
that it can have a line to it.
This is effectively infinite
compared to customer demand
because it's a very,
very high number.
Each of them costs
$1 million to open
and our handling cost is $0.01
per unit as mentioned earlier.
And this check mark allow--
essentially says, do I want
to consider this location?
If I uncheck any of
these, that location
would just be taken out of
consideration right away.
So finally we have
some inputs here
before we run the optimization.
So I mentioned earlier that
you can put a constraint
around your minimum and maximum
number of distribution centers.
And so I'm going to
start off by saying
I'm going to have
a minimum of one,
I need a warehouse somewhere,
and a maximum of 20.
Because there's only 20 options,
here having 20 is your maximum.
It's kind of like saying I'm
willing to take any of them.
The transportation cost per
unit mile is $0.05 as mentioned,
and these are some
more technical things
I won't get into.
All right.
So when I click Run
optimization, what's
happening now is my app
is taking the customer
information, the
distribution center
information, and the maximum and
minimum number of distributions
centers and forming
an optimization
model on the back side
on the Shiny app server.
It then finds the optimal
solution the minimal cost
and returns me--
returns the outputs.
Luckily it worked
as fast in this demo
as it has in my practice.
Right.
So let's look and see what
those optimal solutions are.
So to service all of
our customer demand
for heartland widgets, the
optimal lowest cost solution
is for distribution centers.
One in Omaha, Nebraska, one here
in Minneapolis, one in Chicago,
and one in my old
hometown in Indianapolis.
You can see the cities that are
serviced by each distribution
center are represented by their
color, you know, red for Omaha
and blue for Indianapolis,
green for Chicago,
yellow for Minneapolis.
And they're geographically
separated as we would kind of
expect because
you generally want
to have your customers closer
to your distribution center.
This table is an
alignment table,
which is just the tabular
version of the map
that we're seeing above.
So for example Ames,
Iowa, which is over here,
is serviced by the distribution
center in Omaha, Nebraska.
The farthest distance from
a customer to its servicing
and distribution
center is 415 miles,
and that's from Rapid
City, South Dakota
over here all the way to Omaha.
Take note of that because
we'll actually come back
to that in a little bit.
So what is the
optimal cost here?
The total supply chain cost that
can be the minimal total supply
chain cost in this scenario
is $7.5 million over here.
That includes $4 million
in distribution center
opening cost, $1 million
per distribution center
and four of them, $13,000 for
handling at the distribution
centers, and about $3.5
million in transportation cost.
So our total 4 million plus
13,000 plus 3.5 million
equals $7.5 million, and that is
our absolute lowest total cost.
Now I'm going to make a
small detour before we're
going to do another
scenario to explain
more what we mean by constraints
in supply chain network design.
In optimization
modeling, constraints
are mathematical
limitations on what set
of decisions you can make.
They correspond real
life limitations.
The more constraints you have
in your model and in real life,
the worse your objective
function becomes.
So in this case, the more the
supply chain cost would be.
Optimization modeling including
supply chain network design
is an exercise in understanding
the trade offs involved
and making constraints more or
less restrictive for tighter
or looser, which
is the term of R.
In designing a supply
chain, the tighter
the constraints, the higher
the total cost becomes.
Supply chain design
is partly in around
understanding the additional
expenses associated
with tighter constraints.
Next we'll talk about what a
couple of those constraints
may look like.
So first we see that the
lowest total supply chain cost
occurs when we have four
distribution centers
in these cities up here.
So what would happen
if we actually
force our model to have exactly
three distribution centers?
How will that change our
cost, how will that change
what our network looks like?
This is actually quite
straightforward to see.
All we need to do is go
back to minimum and maximum
number of distribution
center constraints.
So I'm going to change
the minimum to three
and the maximum to three.
Because these are
integer values,
by forcing your minimum and
maximum to both be three,
you're going to end up with
three distribution centers.
And click Run optimization.
And this optimization
model is just
running in the background
with the additional constraint
that it needs exactly
three distribution centers.
I'm going to go back to
my results, it'll refresh.
And now we see that instead
of four distribution centers,
we have the required three.
And it's the same way out
except now Indianapolis is gone.
Sorry to my Hoosier friends.
And so question then, what does
this do to our overall cost?
Because as I mentioned,
the tighter you
make your constraints, the
worse your objective function
becomes in this,
meaning the more
you're going to pay in total.
So let's look at these outputs.
Our DC opening costs
are now $3 million
because we only have
three distribution centers
and they are $1 million apiece.
Our handling cost is
the same because it's
the same for all
distribution centers
and we have the same
amount of volume.
But our transportation
cost, which was $3.5 million
before is now $4.6 million.
So while our distribution
center opening costs went down,
$1 million, our transportation
costs went up $1,100,000.
And so our total cost went from
7.5 million to 7.6 million.
So we see that this one
change increases the cost.
Now, 100,000 is a lot of
money to a normal person.
In the consideration of
a base of 7.5 million,
it's not a big difference,
but it is an increase.
So that's what we see
when we just force exactly
three distribution centers.
Next we'll see what happens when
we enforce a maximum distance
constraint between our
distribution centers
and our customers.
This is often the case
with food supply chains
because food is
perishable and you
don't want your food outside of
a climate controlled warehouse
for too long before
it gets to a store.
And so oftentimes when
designing food supply chains,
you would put in a
distance constraint.
This is actually pretty easy
to do with our Anton table
and using this maximum
miles to DC column.
I'm going to say a maximum
of 400 miles between all
of my customers and my
distribution centers.
As you may remember,
the distance
between Rapid City, South Dakota
and the distribution center
in Omaha, Nebraska
was 415 miles.
So by adding this
additional constraint,
that alignment is not possible.
It's not going to be allowed.
So we just change that column.
Change it back to 1 in
20 and run optimization.
I give this a few more seconds.
And if it doesn't work
as quickly as I thought,
I'll just go on my slide show.
OK.
Instead of weighing that, we'll
just go back to the slideshow
here.
So what would happen if we did
force a 400 mile constraint?
Instead of-- we still have
four distribution centers
as the optimal setting.
But instead of a warehouse
in Omaha, Nebraska,
we would have it in Sioux
Falls, South Dakota.
Why?
Because that is the
distribution center
that allows Sioux Falls, which
is a-- sorry, Rapid City, South
Dakota over here, which
is a very remote customer
to be within 400 miles.
And the impact on
the cost structure
is that instead of $3.5 million
for transportation cost,
we now have $4 million
in transportation cost.
So by adding that additional
constraint around 400 miles
from your distribution
center to your customers,
your total supply chain
cost rose from $7.5 million
to $8 million.
Let's say we actually wanted
to see the overall total cost
at different number of
distribution centers.
I went and ran this model
forcing it to have exactly
one distribution center, exactly
two distribution centers, three
distribution centers,
all the way to nine.
I then recorded
the cost components
between the handling
cost, the opening cost,
and the transportation cost.
The handling cost
in green is flat
no matter how many
distribution centers
you have because it's the
same volume just split
in different ways.
This blue line is our
distribution center
opening cost, which is linear
because with more distribution
centers, you're spending
another $1 million.
Your transportation
cost in red goes down
because as I mentioned, the more
distribution centers you have,
the closer you are on
average to your customers,
so your transportation
cost goes down.
It goes down
dramatically from one
to two distribution centers,
but then kind of flattens out.
So there's not as
much of a benefit.
So your total supply chain
cost, which is this purple line,
is kind of a parabola.
And the minimal cost occurs
at four distribution centers
as we saw before like
between, for example, 2 and 5
is not a tremendous
amount of difference.
And so if I was doing an
actual study for a client,
I'd be presenting something
like this and saying,
actually, while four
distribution centers
is your minimal cost
network, between 2 and 5
there's not much of
a difference in cost
and there's pros and
cons of each of those.
All right.
Well that's most of
the content folks.
So really appreciate
your time today.
Just wanted to wrap up by saying
and emphasizing that supply
chain management really
was behind the scenes
corporate function until
the beginning of the COVID
pandemic, but now it's front
page news we all see it.
And analytics powered by open
source programming languages,
it really is changing
the nature of this field.
Supply chain
network design, it's
kind of obscure part of
supply chain analytics,
but I find it can be a powerful
tool in devising and evaluating
the organization's
supply chain strategy.
And hopefully today,
you just got a taste
of what that might look like.
And thank you for listening.
If you like to know
more, please reach out.
RACHEL: Awesome.
Thank you so much Ralph.
And I just want to--
that was a great presentation--
great presentation.
And I just want to
reiterate to everyone,
I see a bunch of questions
coming in through the Zoom chat
as well.
If you could use the Slido that
would be super helpful so we
can kind of help
see the questions
versus comments in the chat.
But Ralph, I'd love to ask a few
questions that came in on Slido
now and then we can hold a few
others until the end as well.
RALPH ASHER: Absolutely.
RACHEL: But one I
see was from Jerry.
That is how large of a problem
can the open source solvers
handle from your experience?
How often do you
encounter models
that would require
a commercial tool?
RALPH ASHER: Yeah, I mean,
I can speak in generalities.
I found that it's more just
a question around what side
of a machine you put it on.
I've ran some pretty
large optimization models
on open source solvers.
And if you have the right
hardware and, you know,
you're kind of paying
for it in your time
or you're paying for
it in your dollars.
And so if you're willing to wait
an hour longer than you would
otherwise, it's well worth it.
I haven't both in my consulting
and in my corporate work,
I've not encountered
a size of a problem
where an open source
solver couldn't handle it,
just like wouldn't compute.
RACHEL: Thank you.
I see Cynthia had also
asked the question,
do these optimization
packages allow
for optimizing to more than
one success metric at a time,
like cost plus
customer satisfaction?
RALPH ASHER: Yeah, yeah.
And so you can kind of shape
your objective function
to reflect whatever combined
metric you may care about.
So in this case, the objective
function that you saw
was purely a cost function.
But I've in the past done things
like, well, here's my cost
and here's, for example,
a customer service
metric that is also a function
of my decision variables.
And you can weight them.
Now when you see the
output, it's a number.
It doesn't really
reflect like dollar bills
on the table or
anything like that.
But it can kind of--
and the more heavily
you weight cost
versus customer success
or customer satisfaction,
that combined metric can lean
towards one way or the other.
RACHEL: Great.
Thank you.
And I know a few
people had asked this
and were curious about the
Shiny code that you used
and if you would
feel comfortable
sharing your slides as well as
maybe some of the Shiny code.
RALPH ASHER: I'd be
comfortable sharing my slides.
Unfortunately, not the code.
That's kind of a trade
secret thing, but.
RACHEL: And one last question.
And then again, we'll cover
additional questions at the end
as well.
I'm just excited to get
to Laura's talk too.
But the next question was
how did your optimization run
so fast?
Are you using parallel packages?
RALPH ASHER: I
mean, it's partially
running so fast because it's
a small example problem.
But no, I'm not doing any
parallelism or anything,
it's just running on whatever
machines getting spun up
on Shiny Apps.
RACHEL: Thank you so much
Ralph for a great presentation.
And I know there's a bunch
more questions here as well
that we'll cover at the end.
And something I should have
noted from the beginning
is in Slido, if you
wouldn't mind maybe
saying who your question
is for so at the end
it will be easier to separate
them out for Ralph and Laura.
But with that, I'd love to
turn over to second speaker,
Laura Derby rose.
Laura is manager of demand at
Mallinckrodt Pharmaceuticals,
where she's responsible for
statistical forecasting,
forecast visualization, and
forecast accuracy measurement.
With that, I'll turn
it over to you Laura.
LAURA ROSE: Thank you Rachel.
OK.
So I'm going to talk about
our experience at Mallinckrodt
with forecasting demand in R.
So we went through a project
about a year ago to replace
a Software as a Service,
I will not name that
company, my boss
has advised me to not name it,
with an open source solution.
So a little bit
about my background.
I'm a demand manager
as Rachel mentioned.
I work in the supply
chain department.
And in Mallinckrodt, we have a
couple of different divisions.
So I work for the specialty
generics division.
And we make basically
generics that you
might be prescribed when you
go to the doctor or your nurse
practitioner or whoever
you might go to see.
So a lot of pain management,
acetaminophen, other things
as well.
So my main job
responsibilities are
stat forecasting and then
measuring forecast accuracy.
So not just of
the stat forecast,
but also our commercial
partners provide a forecast
based on kind of market
intelligence info
that they've collected.
They do not do stat modeling
as far as I can tell,
but they do submit a forecast.
And then I wanted to add a--
a caveat here that I only had
about five months of experience
regularly programming in R
when I started the project.
And I share that with you
all to hopefully encourage
people who are just getting
started in R or Python
and thinking about doing
a project that will really
involve R or Python.
If you know enough
to write a script,
you probably know enough to
do a project that will really
impact your company.
And I guess I didn't
put this on the slide,
but I'll mention it
since I know Ralph
mentioned academic background.
I am an economist by education.
I've worked most of my
career in supply chain
and really did a little
bit of economic consulting,
but found that I really
enjoyed supply chain.
So here I am.
OK.
So how the project began.
So imagine it's spring 2020.
Actually, you don't
have to imagine, right?
It's probably all still
fresh in our minds.
And your stay home being a good
citizen, and your little bored.
So what did I do?
Created a little Shiny
App, a simple Shiny app
for time series forecasting.
And shout out to the
R Ladies organization.
I actually got the
inspiration for the app
from R Lady St Louis meetup.
And so I used materials that
the presenter had provided
to kind of dig into Shiny.
I had taken a few online
tutorials in Shiny but never
really done much with it.
So, you know, I'm
working remotely.
And I want to impress
to my manager that
hey I'm being productive.
So in one of our calls
I showed him the app.
And he was impressed with it
and he thought, well, maybe we
can replace the SaaS
that we were currently
using for stat forecasting with
this app or something like it.
So the SaaS that we were
using cost about $200,000
per year, which for my
company is not small change.
We were definitely in
a cost savings mode.
It was also generating negative
number demand forecasts.
So keep in mind that that's--
what do you even do
with that, right?
We're not going to
sell a negative number.
The IT support for
this company could not
figure out what was going on.
So it was costing us like
a lot of time and effort
to basically modify
these forecasts.
So after my manager's
initial approval,
I collected some demand data.
We chose about 30
SKUs that we thought
were representative of--
of the business.
And I did a rolling
forecast accuracy analysis.
We wanted to have an idea before
we proceeded further what kind
of accuracy we could expect
if we switch to the R forecast
package that was what I
was using at the time.
I'll go more into that
a little bit later.
And specifically,
the ETS function,
which is the exponential
smoothing commonly used
in univariate supply
chain forecasting,
also the ARIMA function.
And there's options there
for to best fit algorithm
kind of a thing.
So the ETS function was actually
comparable to what was used
and what we had
enabled in the SaaS,
various exponential
smoothing models
were selected by the
demand forecaster.
So I ran this rolling
forecast accuracy analysis.
And to give you an idea of
how perhaps not efficient
I was at the time,
and I'm sure I'll
be saying the same thing about
myself in a couple of years
today, but I had three for
loops that I use to do this.
And anybody who's
programmed in R for a while
knows that's generally
not the best strategy.
But it did work, and we
were satisfied that, hey,
just doing like setting the
ETS algorithm to best fit
minimizing the ICC,
that's the information
criterion and the corrected
one, that was comparable to what
we were getting in terms
of forecast accuracy
from our SaaS.
Also benefit was, hey, we
didn't need manual intervention
from the demand
analyst or manager.
So we made the decision to
move forward with this project
and then we had to get the
buy in from the IT group
at Mallinckrodt, not of
course the IT support
at the SaaS company since
it was in their budget.
Well, as you can
imagine, it wasn't
difficult to get buy in
for a cost savings project.
They were also frustrated
with the lack of support
that we were getting
from the SaaS company
and the time required
that we were all spending
on doing useless tasks.
So up till then, I had
written some other scripts
I'd used for various
data wrangling tasks,
the kind of stuff you do
with supply chain analysis,
right, and demand
planning which is
my specific area of expertise.
And we didn't want to just have
me running scripts on RStudio.
That's not as useful as the
free version of RStudio is.
We wanted more enterprise
capable options.
So we looked into
RStudio Server Pro.
And I believe the
most recent version
of that is called Workbench.
I'm not super up
to date on that.
Then we also contracted
with Lander Analytics,
and they helped with server
setup and maintenance
and an application installation.
So it is a Linux
server for those
of you might be
more Windows people,
and at Mallinckrodt, we're
more of a Windows shop
is what I've been
told by our IT group,
so we definitely needed a little
bit more guidance in setting
that up.
And we had both a
production and dev server
that were supported with them.
OK.
So we're moving forward
in this project,
we made the decision
to go forward.
The IT analyst who was
responsible for maintaining
the data used for
stat forecasting
needed to collaborate with me
to replace the data management.
So not the forecasting,
but those of you
might have used the
SaaS at your company
for forecasting
other things, note
that the SaaS can
sometimes do functions
that are not just the
main function that you
may have purchased it for.
So we needed to do
in-house solutions.
Especially generics is kind
of old school in a way,
so we have like
an AS-400 system.
So we needed to create
a bunch of tables,
make sure we were
maintaining those tables,
devs were running
that kind of thing.
So we had tables for
both cleansed history
and non-cleansed history.
So cleansed meaning
removing outliers.
Sometimes you might decide
to not include all history
for consideration in
the stat forecast model
because there might have been
a structural change, something
like that.
So we wanted to move away
from Excel spreadsheets.
There is definitely a time
and a place for spreadsheets,
but we just didn't feel
that was in the best
interest of the business.
So we used the DBI package,
which probably many of you
are familiar with, and
then the odbc package--
lowercase odbc.
I think there's an
uppercase ROEC package.
And just using some basic
SQL, we got those set up
and it was very easy to
connect to the RA400 system,
pull in those tables that I
would need to estimate models
and calculate forecasts.
We also changed our
outlier cleansing process
as I alluded to in
the second point.
And that is because
we had previously
cleansed the history directly
in the SaaS application.
So we just moved to a
pretty simple process.
We were trying to come up with
something in the limited time
we had.
And we-- we had an Excel upload.
If you needed to
remove an outlier,
you'd upload an Excel
file to RA400 system.
So probably could have been--
well, we're changing
the process actually now
and I'll get more to
that in the future.
But, you know, in
the initial stages
it worked, and sometimes
you have to go with that.
And then we also needed
a table to source
that forecast generated
from the R script so.
As I said before, no
Excel files involved.
We were going to
write that to a table.
And then we also needed
another like a file or a table
so to speak for storing
historical forecasts.
And that is to measure
forecast accuracy.
OK.
So we were able to use RStudio
Server Pro for other uses
besides stat forecasting.
As I alluded to earlier
in my presentation,
I had written some
other R scripts
to do a lot of data
analysis and rankling tests,
the kind of things that
you don't want to spend
a lot of time on if you can.
Measuring weighted
MAPE-- weighted MAPE
is what we use to measure
our forecast accuracy.
There are other metrics that
your organization might use.
Checking the commercial
forecasts upload
versus the download.
I am responsible for loading
the commercial partners
forecast to the ERP system.
And depending on
how things go, we
might have kind of phantom
forecasts hanging out
in the ERP system.
So it's hard to check that
in just doing a spreadsheet
analysis, but it was
fairly simple to write
a program that did it in R.
Also, last year with
the pand-- well,
I said last year because it's
two years ago almost now,
we had a lot of orders
for acetaminophen
with the start of the pandemic.
And our product director needed
some help in understanding
how to allocate orders
and versus forecast.
So we had assortment
of products.
And based on the forecast
the customer provided,
they were either going
to get product or have
to kind of go to the end
of the line, so to speak.
And there were some other
one for the sake of time,
I won't bore you guys
with the details of those.
So it was very-- it was
simple to set these jobs up
to run on the server
using CronR And that's,
as you would expect
by the name, it's
an R package which
interfaces with Cron.
So the script saved a lot
of time all these jobs set.
Up we could compile
a lot of data
reports with no intervention,
or maybe a little bit of just
give it a check from
demand managers.
And then the real test is
when I was out on short term
disability this past summer.
The jobs ran well.
They saved my
coworker a lot of time
having to cover my
responsibility as well as his.
So my coworker left the
company in November,
so I've since been taking
over his former duties.
And I've been writing various
R scripts to kind of hopefully
improve some of the processes.
And it really has
made it possible
scheduling these jobs on the
RStudio Server Pro interface.
It has really made it possible
for me to do my job as well
as his previous duties
OK.
To summarize the
project, you're probably
wondering how long
did all this take.
It took about 11 months.
And I will say this.
You could probably do
this kind of project
where you totally
replace the software
you've been using in less time.
We happened to
have a lot of time
based on when the contract with
the SaaS was going to be up.
And so we had several months
in early 2021 where we
were running both concurrently.
There are definitely
improvements
to be made to the
forecasting processes,
and I can tell you
that as well as anybody
at the company, that's what
I deal with day in day out.
But the initial goal
of replacing the SaaS
with solution at least as
effective was completed.
So we consider that the
initial stage to be a success.
We measure on a LAG 3 forecast
accuracy, which basically takes
into consideration--
essentially,
it's sort of like LAG 4
if you think about it.
Takes history from
four months ago
when you're measuring the
particular month in question.
But it's been about the same.
Depending on the month,
a little bit worse,
a few percentage points.
But we did meet
our goal for 2021.
So my boss is happy, I'm happy.
And the cost savings
is definitely
worth it for a slight
trade often accuracy.
And we are still using pretty
simple models like ARIMA
exponential smoothing models.
So we hope that as we
introduce new models,
we will improve
accuracy over time.
And then I alluded to this
earlier in the presentation.
So I started out with
the forecast package
in summer 2020.
And then I found out--
I guess it was probably old
news but it was new news to me
at that time about the
tidyverts suite of packages,
which is kind of the replacement
for the forecast package.
And so I switched to that.
I switched over the code
that I had written to that.
It took a little
bit to kind of make
sure I understood everything.
But it's a great
suite of packages
that includes stable
fees, stable data I think.
So I have found
those to be really
useful for automatic forecasting
if you have a lot of SKUs
and you don't have time to
go in and tweak parameters,
figure out the
best reader model,
figure out the best
exponential smoothing model,
for instance like
univariate forecasting.
The models, they produce--
the forecast for supply chain
are stable forecasts.
They don't require a
lot of intervention,
you're not going to get anything
unbelievable or crazy I guess.
OK.
So I mentioned the
Shiny app earlier.
So the impetus of the project
started with a simple time
series forecasting app.
We made the decision to
forecast the script scheduled
as a monthly job
instead of an app.
And part of the reason
for that seemed simpler
at the time, time savings.
Also, it ended up working out.
We weren't really ready
to go with RStudio Connect
at the time, which
we would have needed
to host the app for an
enterprise capable way.
So after that, I developed
another Shiny app
kind of based on my first
one, which is more--
uses a number of
different packages,
the tidyverts
packages of course,
DT, I think Ralph mentioned that
in his app, to edit history,
you can change parameters.
Basically interfaces with
RA400 system via SQL.
So you can--
through the app, you
can interactively edit our
data in our company systems.
And this allows
me to, especially
for those high volume
really important
SKUs, to go in and
pick out specifications
I think are optimal.
So we're hoping that
this will give us
more opportunity to kind of
tune a better model for the SKUs
that we consider to
be A SKUs important.
The impetus for
creating this app
was actually my former coworker.
And he wanted
something that mimics
some of the functionality that
we had in our previous SaaS.
So he liked being able to
go in, play with parameters,
kind of test things out.
See of how he could
change the history, how
does this change the
forecast, that kind of thing,
look at different
accuracy metrics
as he was creating his forecast.
So future state.
It's always good to be thinking
about continuous improvement,
right?
So I'm working on
another Shiny app
to visualize our generic data,
that's our finished dosage
data with the pivot table
probably using the pivot tabler
package.
Not sure yet.
I might look into a
few other packages.
And then we either look
at monthly or weekly doses
or bottles depending on
what the user would want.
So I currently use
this very slow tool
using a legacy system
I will not name.
And we use this for creating
visualizations for the demand
review slide deck, where we
look at our customer demand
compare that to our--
look at our forecast
to see what's changed,
look at our financials,
that kind of a thing.
So this will helped me
more than anybody else,
but I'm definitely interested
in improving my processes.
And then another
project we started
last month is looking at the
commercial team forecasts.
So they currently don't use
much statistical forecasting.
So they are interested though
in looking at their end purchase
or demand and how
we can roll that up
under distributor customers.
Mallinckrodt is a manufacturer,
so we sell to some big time
distributor customers you may
have heard of in the news.
And there are certain customers
that are pricing contracts,
and then those
distributor customers
sell to more of the retail
pharmacies kind of a thing.
So we're hoping to get a
better picture of our demand
to kind of tie that
out and build a better
forecast for them in that way.
And then in terms of
model improvement,
those of you who are familiar
with the tidyverts packages
probably know that you can
do hierarchical forecasting
as well.
We did explore that a little
bit in the initial stages
of the project,
excuse me, when we
were trying to understand
what we wanted,
how much we wanted to experiment
with different kinds of models.
My boss thought it wasn't
a good idea at the time,
but now that we've
completed the initial stage,
we'll probably look into
that a little bit more.
And then also machine learning
methods for time series.
We would need to do
that on weekly data.
We don't have enough
monthly data really
to make it worth it.
But model time is
a good package.
So that is something that
probably this year we
are looking into exploring.
So to summarize, I just--
a lot of on this slide
is common sense but I think
it's probably worth reiterating.
You're interested in
doing like a project where
you replace a SaaS
with an R solution,
start sooner versus later.
Something that we learned
sometimes the hard way
is that the SaaS will
perform other functions
besides forecasting.
So you need to come up with
solutions for data storage
and management.
And those solutions
might be R specific.
They need to be compatible
with whatever you're
doing in R for forecasting.
So you might need to create
a database, a data warehouse,
maybe you already have
something like that
at your company or
your organization.
Also project
management 101 I guess,
make sure you beat estimate
the time involved on your part
as well as many collaborators
because you don't want
to come up to the
end of the project
and figure out that they don't
have enough time to give you--
to complete the project.
And then I wish somebody had
told me this ahead of time.
Learning some project
management skills is helpful.
Probably a lot of
us on this call
have good technical skills.
When I was trying to map
out this process which
is my subsequent point,
I had really no idea
what I was doing.
And it got done, but it could
have been a lot more efficient.
And then I feel like I might be
a little bit of a broken record
here, but you don't
want to realize
you have an account for
something you previously
relied on the SaaS to
do when you've almost
completed the project.
And as you probably expect,
we learned the hard way.
My coworker used the
SaaS for something.
I did not exactly know
what he was doing.
And I think there was
a miscommunication
between perhaps an
IT analyst and him.
Just throwing blame, but
we realized oh, we never
accounted for this.
Now we're practically
finished with this project
and we need to make
sure we have something
that will allow him to do
what he did with the SaaS.
So you don't want
to-- you don't want
to have our experience there.
And then I I'll finish.
Hopefully this is not
too pessimistic a note,
but with a paraphrasing
of Murphy's law,
something can go
wrong, it will, so
plan for all the contingencies.
And since we're all in
supply chain planning,
that shouldn't be too hard.
OK.
That's all I've got.
Questions I guess Rachel?
I don't know how we're
going to do this.
RACHEL: Yeah.
I can help with reading this.
But thank you so much, Laura.
That was an awesome
presentation.
Really appreciate it.
I see a lot great comments
in the chat as well.
And I just want
to remind people,
if you could use the
Slido link to ask
questions, that is super helpful
for helping us organize them.
But I did see one question
that just came through quickly
on the chat was if you
could please repeat
the name of the package that
you use which allows a user
to edit data interactively.
LAURA ROSE: Oh, sure.
Sure.
DTE.
But I know, and
Ralph mentioned this
in his presentation, R hands
on table is another good one.
And there are other
ones out there.
I was familiar with and I'd
already gone down that path,
so I was just like
I'm sticking with it.
If I was building
it from scratch,
maybe I'd do R Hands on Table.
But yeah, there are several
good packages out there.
RACHEL: Cool.
Thank you.
Another question from
Slido was what type of data
are you forecasting on?
Invoice sales, demand, POS?
LAURA ROSE: Demand data.
So we have two divisions.
Yeah, invoice sales,
it's by request date.
So it's not shipment.
It's supposed to be a
representation of what
our true demand is.
So not taking into
account any supply issues.
So we sell business to business.
So we supply a lot of the
pharmaceutical companies you
probably heard of in the news.
And that's all I
can say about that.
And then we also supply
some distributor pharmacies,
and that's our dosage product.
So the kind of
stuff that you might
get prescribed for pain
management or other conditions.
RACHEL: Thank you.
But Laura, one question was,
if you had unlimited budget,
would you prefer,
one, modeling in R
and then passing results to
Tableau, or two, modeling
and displaying in R and Shiny?
LAURA ROSE: So R and Shiny
is a clear winner for me.
So I have used a commonly--
I can't name names, but
a commonly used data
visualization tool, which
is kind of a click and drag
and everything.
And I just don't find it--
I like to know what's
going on behind the scenes.
And when I'm writing
in Shiny code,
I know how things fit together.
But when I'm doing-- if I
was focusing more in Tableau
or another tool, I wouldn't--
any of those visualizations
that can be done in Tableau, but
I wouldn't have the same sense
of control.
So that's my
personal preference,
and I'm not saying
it's the right one.
RACHEL: Thanks Laura.
And I'm going to try and also
pull people into the discussion
and allow people
to unmute yourself.
I know this is dangerous
with 300 people.
But Eduardo, I saw you had
a great question that you
put into the Slido as well.
And I was wondering if you'd
want to read that one out loud
and add some context there.
And I can start by
reading the question too.
But it was Laura, did you have
to deal with uploading back
the forecast to ERP?
If that was the case,
were there any guidelines
you had to follow with IT?
LAURA ROSE: So you're talking
to stat forecast I assume?
I mean, I know I mentioned
doing a check of an upload.
So I'm assuming you're
going with stat forecast
because that's what the models
estimated then calculate in R.
So I actually worked-- the
nice thing about designing
the system on your own, again,
maybe I'm a control freak
but I hope not, is
that I had a chance
to work with the IT analyst.
And he and I have a very
good working relationship
to say OK, this is the kind
of table we want to build.
I need this field, I need
this field, I need this field.
So we kind of have a
custom solution built.
I think within my--
within the service account,
which we use in RStudio,
it's not tied to my
personal account,
so it can run if I'm on short
term disability or whatever.
I think we had to have like
permissions set so that anybody
you could write with that
account to the table.
A pretty simple fix though.
So no, they were basically
like what do you need from IT,
and I was like, here's what I
want, here's where I want it.
They said OK.
RACHEL: Great.
Thanks Laura.
One other question that
came through on Slido
was how do you store
snapshots of your forecast
for later accuracy analysis?
LAURA ROSE: OK, yeah.
I kind of did allude
to that I guess.
This is something
that IT team handles.
I guess I could
theoretically do this in R.
But at the end of the
month, before the table that
receives the forecast is
cleared that forecast,
so all 67,000 now lines
of it or whatever,
we forecast three years out.
Nothing magical about three
years, just how we do it.
It's copied to
another table that
has I think we saw 13 months
of historical forecasts.
And then what I measure
statistical MAPE,
the script pulls in from that
historical table filters.
I use some of the
DVI interfaces,
and in the parameter
argument, you
can say I want to pull in
based on this criteria.
Can you pull in whatever
might be your LAG 3
forecast or LAG 1.
So that's how we measure it.
But yeah, we do track our
stat forecast accuracy
pretty carefully.
RACHEL: Great.
Thank you so much, Laura.
And I see there are
a ton of questions
that have come in here too.
So a few of them
don't say if it's
for Ralph or Laura
either or both.
So I'd love to throw
some questions at you
as well Ralph from earlier too.
But one was, Ralph,
what R packages
do you use for operations
research optimization problems?
RALPH ASHER: Yeah.
So for optimization,
the biggest ones I use
is the ompr, which stands for
I think optimization modeling
process in R. I'm
not sure about the P.
And essentially, it's
a pretty intuitive way
to take one of your program
or any of your program
optimization models and
formulate them in R.
And that's kind of
modeling language package.
And then there's some
adjacent packages
that actually then send it
to the solver of your choice.
And so if you go on the
packages at GitHub site,
it's very easy to read.
But I like that
because it's built
with a tidyverse
centric mindset.
So for example, you use pipes
to add components of your model.
And you can do
whatever code you need
to do to prep your input
tables and then just send it
into your optimization
model, which
is how I'm able to kind of
dynamically change the inputs
and then react demise
on the back end.
That's probably what I use.
RACHEL: Great, thank you.
And one other
question for Laura.
And then I'll turn
it over to you Curtis
and then I'll go back
to open the discussion
and remainder of the questions.
But the question
Laura was thanks
for the inspiring presentation.
How did you manage R package
updates in your organization?
Did the IT admin control
the package updates?
LAURA ROSE: That's
a good question.
I'm trying to think.
The first thing is I
guess I should come clean
that I probably don't to pay my
packages as often as I should.
I am actually the only
user of R in my division.
I'm not sure about we
have specialty brands too.
So in terms of managing
across the organization,
it hasn't been an
issue at this point.
If we do bring on
another analyst
or we have a current person who
learns R and kind of decides
to do some stuff with
it, that'll probably
become more of an issue.
But I do use--
it isn't quite exactly your
question, maybe it's helpful.
I use R 3--
no, I feel bad admitting
this, but 3.6.3
for some of my scripts.
But then I use 4.1.0
for stat forecasting
because we do use parallel
processing for part of that.
And it's just--
the time difference
was-- we were getting
time out issues.
It was just really
a big difference,
when you set up a job, you
can specify which version of R
you want to use.
That's not package
question though,
but you can use
both, that's nice.
RACHEL: Awesome.
Thank you Laura.
And Curtis, I'd
love to turn it over
to you to have you kind
of give us some more
information on the
working group that we're
trying to form as well
and to kind get us
all thinking about what
resources what we might
want to contribute there too.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone
for presenting
and we'll get back to the
questions in a moment.
But we also did want to take
an opportunity with this group.
There's obviously
a lot of interest
in combining open
source software
to solve the problems that
folks in supply chain management
have.
The kind of too long
didn't read or didn't
listen version of
what I'm about to say
is if you consider yourself one
of two people, either keenly
interested in community
organizing for supply chain
management or keenly interested
in contributing resources
to the community, whether it be
our packages or articles, kind
of sharing best practices that
other people could benefit
from, I really encourage you
to have a look at the link
that I just shared.
It's an rstd.io link.
Have a read over the kind
of proposal we present there
and consider participating
and submitting your name.
The longer version
is, right, there's
a lot of interest in
supply chain management
plus open source software.
And so Rachel, Ralph, and I
had talked a couple of months
ago now actually about
how to take this community
to the next level.
There's certainly a
lot of industry groups
as well as field groups that
have set kind of templates
that communities could follow.
So I have a lot of colleagues
in pharma for example,
and they have a nice conference
that brings everyone together
and shares resources.
A lot of groups
create share packages
with kind of common solutions.
There's a lot of
ways to approach it.
We propose a working
group to kind of create
a community hub
for you folks where
you could share resources and
share best practices that you
would all then be able to
benefit from and develop
together.
So again, if you kind
of consider yourself
one of those two
groups, I would really
encourage you to have
a look at that link
and consider
submitting your name.
What we do after that is
we'll follow up shortly
after to kind of bring those
folks together and continue
the conversation about
how to take this community
to the next level.
The other thing I did
mention is I'm Curtis.
I work at RStudio.
I'm community organizer.
I Have been with you
with our RC for a while,
and watching the community
grow for four years.
So super happy to
be a part of this.
Thank you so much, Curtis.
And if anybody has
questions about that too,
please feel free to even raise
your hand on this Zoom call
or reach out to me directly too.
But I see Curtis, you shared
that link in the chat there.
Awesome.
I know there are a ton of
questions still on Slido,
so I can go over to those too.
But also, if you're here
and have a burning question
that you love to
ask live as well,
feel free to raise your hand on
Zoom too and I can call on you.
Laura, one other question
that looks like it came in
pretty recently was did you
experience any challenges
in change management when it
came to convincing stakeholders
to use the analytics
tools and forecasts?
LAURA ROSE: No, I didn't.
And that's because it was less
work for pretty much everybody.
Yeah.
So if you can make
people's lives simpler,
it's very easy to get by if you
can convince them to do that.
I was recently on a call
with the director of IT
as well as my boss who's the
senior director of supply
chain.
And the director was like, yeah,
it's saving us $200,000 a year.
It's less work for
the IT analyst.
And he's like, yeah, it's
been great, you know.
So I think my old
coworker, he I think
liked having not
to do as much work
because I also had some scripts
that did his MAPE processing
and other things for him,
helped him check his forecast
upload, that kind of thing.
So make people's
lives simpler and they
will be happy to change
in my experience.
I love that.
And I see one of the
most upvoted questions
right now is I hope you got a
raise for the $200,000 in cost
savings.
I did get--
I did get a raise
and a promotion.
So.
Congratulations.
So a few other questions here.
So for Ralph, there is one.
How do you incorporate
uncertain inputs
like Laura's demand
forecast into models
to be run in
deterministic solvers?
RALPH ASHER: Yeah,
it's a good question.
So this is kind of where the
R and science come together.
And so there's a couple of ways.
The way I primarily like to use
is essentially use simulation
to change the inputs.
So for example, if the
demand for Ames, Iowa
was not this number,
but rather we
think it's from here
to here, you kind of
do a sampling of each of those
and you run the optimization.
And overall, you do
this a bunch of times
to kind of compare the outputs
and see how different really
are the recommendations.
Like if it's always recommending
these four warehouses,
those four warehouses
are a good choice.
If there is radically
different outputs,
then you kind of got to
dig a little bit deeper.
Thanks Ralph.
I see-- another question was--
it could be for either
of you, but could you
talk a bit more about compliance
for an in-house application?
RALPH ASHER: Yeah,
Rachel-- or sorry,
Laura, would you
mind taking that?
LAURA ROSE: Sure, yeah.
So compliant.
I'm not sure I entirely
understand the question.
If you are able to get
a little more color
and put that in the
chat or somewhere else,
perhaps Rachel can give
me some insight into that.
Because we use statistical
forecasting, we were using it
I was going to say,
it's more of a benchmark
for our commercial
partners, there wasn't
a lot of compliance
present in our pharma,
especially opiates, which
is one of the products
that Mallinckrodt makes.
It's very highly
regulated as you know.
But the commercial
teams, their forecast
has to submit a lot
more customer level
evidence to the DEA for quota.
For statistical
forecasts, we're basically
saying what is our demand say.
So there wasn't as much
of a compliance issue.
And my company, I will
say for being a fairly
large organization, people
are pretty agile about hey,
if something works
and we like it,
we're going with it as
long as we're not obviously
breaking any laws or
circumventing regulations.
So if you have any more
compliance-- like I see someone
says compliance
with IT standards.
Yeah, I mean they were--
I'm very fortunate to have
an I really chill IT team.
But they were like,
yeah, let's go for it.
It sounds good, as long as
they get the time to do it,
which they did.
And then I see someone
else said compliance,
my financial division
will kill me if I do that.
Well, I mean, I go back
to my previous comment.
If you can simplify their lives,
maybe they would reconsider.
So hopefully that's helpful.
I like that idea of
simplifying other people's
lives to push things forward.
Another upvoted
question was what
metrics do you use to
measure forecast accuracy?
And I'm not sure if you
had covered this at all.
LAURA ROSE: Yeah, I
guess I briefly touched
on it in my presentation.
We use weighted MAPE.
How we define that, there's a
couple different definitions,
but it's basically the sum
of of the absolute variances.
So we measure it at SKU level.
You can do it at
different levels.
Forecast minus demand or
absolute forecast minus
demand over the sum
of all the demand.
So that essentially
gives more weight
to higher volume SKUs
relatively speaking.
I mean, it's all aggregated,
but we don't really
pay attention as much to
the little volume SKUs
because, hey, if they're
really accurate or they're not,
their absolute variances that
aren't going to be that big.
Thanks Laura.
And I know I
mentioned this before,
but if you have a
question and you
want to ask it
out loud too, feel
free to raise your hand
on Zoom or even just
unmute yourself and jump in.
I know it's very hard to
recreate that in person
feel virtually, but we'd
love to hear from you all.
XIAN: I have a question.
RACHEL: Sure.
Go ahead.
XIAN: So I am looking into
breaking into the R scene,
but I have a little bit of
prior experience but not much.
How do you recommend
I go into this?
Should I start learning
R first like the syntax
and all that and
then doing a project
or should I just dive right
in and start doing projects
that I can find
plenty of on Kaggle?
I'm happy to take this.
Ralph, if you want to chime in.
I feel like I've been
talking a lot, but I'm--
I have less experience than you.
So I guess it's more
recent in my memory.
Yeah OK.
I'll give my opinion.
I'm sure Ralph will have some
interesting things to add.
I would say want
to be at the level
where you can at least
understand how functions work.
I mean, tidyverse
is really kind of--
I know people like
data table too,
I personally am not
familiar with it.
But tidyverse is kind
of an essential I
would say for supply chain.
You know, you're doing all this
data analysis and manipulation
wrangling all that
kind of stuff.
You should be able
to comfortably write
at least a simple R script.
And you do learn
as you go along.
Sometimes the best
way to learn is
to actually pursue something.
I think once you have a
deadline, that's where it all
becomes real, you know.
So make sure that
you've got something
working before you give the
cancel notice to your SaaS
or whatever else
you're going to be
doing that's going to involve
money on the line I guess.
That's my advice.
But yeah, I mean, if you
can write a simple R script,
you're probably ready to
start some kind of project.
Go for it.
Yeah I concur.
I mean, the vast majority
of work in supply chain
is data prep and data analysis.
So you can start with kind
of a tidyverse is education.
That's probably best.
And then just learning
functional programming
from there is good.
Thanks.
I'll read one of the
Slido questions to you,
but again, raise
your hand on Zoom
too if you want to jump in.
VIRESH BAUDHANWALA:
I have a question.
RACHEL: Oh, there you go.
Yep.
Yes.
VIRESH BAUDHANWALA: Yes ma'am.
For forecasting--
for forecasting in--
wait, wait.
In forecasting in supply chain
system, the reason [INAUDIBLE]
for forecasting matter like
time series forecasting
econometric model judgment
and forecasting and delivery
method.
So which is adopted for
the precise outcome.
So judgmental
forecasting really
wouldn't involve any
statistical modeling per se.
You would kind of just
say I think this is best.
Some of what our
commercial partners do,
I think they do some trending
and things like that.
I have not quite gotten a
super clear explanation,
which I will probably be
learning more about that as I
go into this project with them.
Delphi method, if I'm my
memory serves me accurately
and someone feel free
to jump in on the chat
if I got this wrong as kind of
a consensus panel of experts.
I mean, that would
probably more not
fall under this kind of project.
And there might be some products
for which you want to do that.
But that's not at the mid-level
manager high-level analysts
data scientists role.
It's probably not what you
would be doing as much.
Unless you maybe you could
put a variable in the model
that, I'm just
brainstorming here,
that would account for that.
But I'm not involved
in that in my company.
I see Todd has asked
the question on Slido that
was is the distance calculation
line of sight or road network
based?
What options are
available to the solution?
I think that might be Ralph.
RALPH ASHER: Yeah.
Yeah, so it is line
of sight, just kind
of as the crow flies for speed.
You can certainly do
road distance calculation
and use it.
It's just a distance
matrix input.
Like for example, you can use--
there's some open
source options.
For my work I use
Google Maps API
because that's kind of the
gold standard of quality
and it's quite easy to use.
Yeah, you can do it either way.
In this particular demo
it's just straight line.
Rachel, I see something
from a Zohar in the chat
that I wanted to address.
I don't think she set her
microphone or he or she's phone
is not working correctly.
So the question is, how do
you handle special events
like promotions and
advertising your stat models?
So their company runs a
lot of promotions but not
during the same months.
So this is a case where you
would definitely probably want
some sort of time
series regression model.
In generics, we
cannot do promotions.
So we can't say, hey, we got
a hydro promotion going on.
Not like us if we did that.
So in that kind of industry
like a consumer packaged goods
perhaps or something, if you had
a forecast from there was going
to happen and then maybe a
past time series of that,
you would want to put that
as an explanatory variable
in your model.
I see one from Yoni.
How do you describe your
clients counterparts?
What factors are driving
your optimization forecasting
models?
This might be for both
Ralph and I. Let's see.
Well, there's just me
in demand planning now.
So my boss and I--
he's got a pretty good
technical understanding
of things.
The big concern at my company,
and this is not every company,
is forecast accuracy.
So if the accuracy
is good, if I could
be doing the most complicated
machine learning model
that anybody ever
thought of, it wouldn't
make that much of a difference.
But I do realize that that's
not the same for everybody else.
So Ralph, you
probably have a couple
of things to add about
that or address about that.
Yeah.
I mean, it's largely like
saying, OK, here's how--
here's how our model
solving this is happening.
Like what's underneath the
hood in the business sense.
Here's the three
cost components,
here's how you might
see the trade offs.
Sometimes, it gets
a little bit tricky
because sometimes
you see outputs that,
oh, that doesn't make sense.
Well, it actually does
once you take into account
all the constraints
and things like that.
But you just need to hopefully
build the credibility first
that they can take the hand
wave explanation at that point.
Thanks Ralph.
I know we're getting to
30 minutes past the hour.
So we have a few
more questions here.
And I know a lot of
people have to drop.
But I do want to say if anybody
wants to stay on and just kind
of chat with each other, we
can stay on past the time too,
maybe pretend like
we're all in person.
But one of the questions was how
have you dealt with time series
model forecasting
when there has been
such a large change in
values, for example,
the price of things?
LAURA ROSE: So that's
a really good question.
I would say if you
have pricing data,
you could put that, like
price elasticity of demand,
you can put that as an
explanatory variable
in your model.
I was dealing with
univariate here.
And univariable is not
always the best choice
if you have things
that correlate well.
In my company, we have
pricing contracts,
so our price actually
does not change very much.
And I think our commercial
team is not particularly--
they don't like to
change price very much.
Which means if you don't
have enough x variation
in your data, it's not
going to be a good--
you wouldn't include
in your model.
Let's see.
I think that mostly
address that.
But yeah, if you--
I mean, the moral of the
story is I think I probably--
maybe, I'm sounding like
a broken record here,
if you can do a regression
or some other type of model
where you're bringing
other factors,
do it because you're
probably going
to get some more
information there
if you find good correlation
between the outcome
and the predictors.
Thanks Laura.
Ralph, I see you had
answered this on Slido,
but someone really
wants to know this
and I see a few questions
coming in with this.
Which optimization algorithm
did you use in your app?
RALPH ASHER: So it's a
mixed integer linear program
for those who are
both operations
research terminology.
Essentially, the OPR
package builds the model
based upon your parameters
and then sends it to a solver.
And solvers-- a lot of
dedicated people work in those,
but essentially it uses a
lot of different approaches
to solving the problem and
picks the best one essentially.
Great Thank you.
Mohit-- Mohit.
I'm probably pronouncing
your name wrong.
I see you had asked the
question or you raised your hand
as well.
If you want to jump in.
MOHIT: Oh, yes.
So my question was regarding
the correlation factor--
the correlation analysis which
Laura was speaking about,
like if the price is
correlated with the demand,
like you just put it as
an external variable.
So does that require any
analysis beforehand you
put in those external
variables or you could just
dump all the variables
you are thinking which
might be correlated and
let the algorithm decide
which ones are best?
So what is the correct approach?
I just wondered about that/
You question, I had to
teach a class on that.
And it's funny you bring this
up because I see someone,
Federica, hey, Federica.
I think she's from
a book club ESL
that I'm in where they
talk about different models
or different ways to select the
variables you want to include.
I mean, a correlation matrix
is a good for a start.
Obviously if you see something
that's not highly correlated,
you may want to
consider dropping it.
Academics versus business people
approach things a little bit
differently in terms of how
they would think about a model
and report that.
I'm assuming your prop might
be in business, I don't know.
But yeah, you could--
there's different methods.
Maybe I should say
join the ISMR book
if you want to find out
more about subset selection.
But correlation is a
good way to get started.
And then think about does it
have any theoretical basis?
If it does, then maybe
you should include it.
At least try it out
in the beginning.
But without seeing data,
it's kind of hard for me
to give a more in-depth answer.
So hopefully that helps you out.
Thank you so much, Laura.
And I see there is also
another question that
is what is the best way to
connect with both of you
Laura and Ralph
after the meeting
if people wanted to ask follow
up questions or connect?
Is it LinkedIn.
Yeah, LinkedIn or email.
LinkedIn is fine.
I think a lot of us get a
lot of spam in our inbox.
I try to respond to messages
that don't look too spammy.
I think my email might
be in my LinkedIn.
But yeah, you're
welcome to email me.
I mean, I'll try to respond.
I've actually pretty
much taken emails.
But yeah, feel free to--
feel free to discuss.
Isn't there a chat
supply chain on the R
on the for data science Slack
too if you're interested,
that's a good.
I mean, it's not super
active, but there's no reason
why it couldn't be more active.
Definitely.
I was just going to
mention that too.
So after the first R
in supply chain meetup,
we did make a group on the R
for Data Science online learning
community.
And so it is chat-supplychain.
And if anybody wants
to join that crew,
I'll put the link in to
join that flat community
in the channel or in
the Zoom chat too.
I see Federica put something
in about the book club.
So yeah, if you--
I would say those book clubs.
I guess, I'll give
a shout out to--
I want to get a shout
out to the book clubs.
Really good way to kind discuss
with like minded individuals
different modeling techniques.
Especially if you don't have
somebody in your organization
that is also doing
this kind of stuff
or if you're working
remotely, it's
a nice way to connect with
like minded individuals.
Definitely.
And I did just put my
LinkedIn there too.
Feel free if anybody has any
other follow up questions
or wants to connect
there or share
your own LinkedIn in the chat
too to network with each other.
Also somebody had
asked if it was
OK to share an open job posting
in the chat channel as well.
Definitely.
So if anybody on the call
is hiring for supply chain
professionals, please feel
free to share that there too.
And thank you
Federica for putting
the link to the book club too.
VIRESH BAUDHANWALA:
Can I ask one question?
RACHEL: Sure.
Yeah.
So my question is
how any organization
utilize the customer sentiment
to forecast or demand forecast
for supply chain analysis.
How any organization utilizes--
May ask what-- may I ask
what industry you're in?
Consumer packaged
goods or durable goods?
I mean, are you
talking about maybe
getting a-- are you talking
about a government data index?
I think there are--
it's been a while since I
did economic consulting,
but I think there are data that
you can download sentiment.
So I mean, you could
download that data.
I think there's probably
some R packages that
could do that and put it as
a predictor in your model.
That's something I think
maybe you could if you really
want to be creative and you had
surveys from your own customers
maybe you could construct
some kind of index
that you read in
that survey data
and assign a
numerical weighting.
You could use that or
other kind of feedback
from perhaps a website
or something else.
I haven't worked in
consumer packaged
goods for several
years, so I'm not super
up on whatever might
be the new techniques,
but those are a couple of
ideas that come to my mind.
Thanks Laura.
Vesalius, I did see
your hand was raised,
so I love to just have
that be the last question
too if you want to jump in.
Thank you Rachel.
And thank you both
to Ralph and Laura
for our great presentations.
So just a very quick question
to anyone who's actually
relevant to the subject.
Have you also used-- have
you also measured bias
to optimize your forecasts
or just accuracy measures?
And if you did, how
did you do that?
NAR, outside the bar?
Just some basics.
Yeah, yeah.
I missed that question
in the chat earlier,
so thank you for asking that.
We do measure bias.
Well we have-- so bias for I
think perhaps maybe on the call
notice, but it's basically
the variance over the demand.
So some of the variances.
So that is basically
directionally,
you under forecast
or over forecast.
It's actually a big
point of discussion
right now for our
commercial partners.
For stat forecasts, we're
more focused on accuracy.
But yeah, if you have
the data and how we--
we use a lot of Excel.
My coworkers love
Excel spreadsheets,
these giant spreadsheets.
Hey, it is what it is,
so I work with that.
Open XLSX, say that five times
fast, is a great package.
But I can write that data
in and we do track it.
And it's important because I
think a lot of times people
do get focused on
accuracy and then--
I actually think that
one of our divisions,
and they have this
consistent bias.
But we're only like
5% weighted MAPE.
It's like we're great.
One's like, well, there's some
inventory building up there.
So yes, that is really
important to do.
And you should be able-- if
you have absolute variance,
you might have created
a variance field,
so you could potentially
use that and just
calculate your bias
at the same time.
Thank you so much.
And thank you all
so much for joining.
I just don't want anyone to feel
like you have to stay around,
but if you want to hang
out with us all and maybe
just chat informally,
feel free to stay on.
We just want to say thank you
so much to Ralph and Laura
for your awesome presentations.